so what can
say somebody watching this is concerned
about famine is there anything that the
average person can do to either prepare
or fight back yeah many things one is
at this point now
in january of 2020 when i first started
warning about it we could have still
averted it at this point there's too
much inertia we're clearly going to have
global famines i don't actually and i'm
a very positive thinking type of a man
you know i just don't see a way out of
this at this point
so now it's down to mitigation right um
even though it hasn't really started in
earnest yet it's all about conditions
again amateurs always talk sparks it's
about conditions the conditions are set
for huge global famines one is it
depends on your conditions right
how you should prepare um
if you live on key west so you've got
one set of issues and one set of you
know it's warm you don't have to worry
about freezing the death
you're also not going to have a big farm
right you know i mean you're not going
to grow anything down there um
you're going to be short on food let's
say if you live in any of the island
nations if you live in japan which
imports about seventy percent of the
fruit or so right or if you live in
hawaii imports about ninety percent of
the food
you're going to be short you're and you
you know you're going to be uh
bidding against the world on the price
of that food right uh like for instance
if i were in hawaii
i mean if i were if i were you know uh
some rich guy that lived on one little
island off from the south there you know
i would look at it differently than
living in honolulu i would be thinking
about going somewhere else but if you
live up in northern canada or i've been
up the yellow knife you know and that
sort of thing i'd be looking at it very
differently so first look at your own
circumstances where do you live uh what
are your economic conditions what are
your capabilities uh uh stocking up can
can be good for short-term sorts of
things that's what i've done as a work
correspondent i have basically hidden
acorns all over the place so if i get to
one of my acorns i'm good to go as a
workhorse model i can't just stop and
grow a bunch of food so that my set of
problems so i look at my problems what
are my problems as a workforce plan my
my
my weaknesses are i'm traveling all the
time so i can't just stop and build a
compound you know and uh and not that
that would be necessarily the best way
to go anyway and my strengths are i do
travel around all the time and so and
and i'm very knowledgeable about
different circumstances around the world
and the united states and so i've
basically implant you know put little
acorns of food if i can get to one of
them i can
you know be there for a long period of
time and and be quite healthy and that
sort of thing uh but other people if you
live in new york city where are you
going to get your food from uh if your
electricity goes out if you're in and
the the thing is is famines tend to
cause
a general a lot of people say united
states can't go into famine and to that
i would say you haven't studied much yet
you know the united states absolutely
can go into famine and at this point
parts of it certainly could and at this
point i would say probably greater than
50 chance at this point that parts of
the united states will go into famine
between somewhere
i don't know 2023 2024 2025. it's all
about conditions right and right now
we're living off the food that we've
already produced right
and uh and our production is diminishing
uh
like it's going off the cliff right
so what would you do look at your own
circumstances what are your own
capabilities how much resources do you
have uh and um and one of the most
things that's most important is
as individuals we're all quite weak
right
uh
one of my principal strengths is i know
a lot of highly capable people so i've
been working on my network right and
that's what everybody should work on is
their networks right your network of
people because as individuals we're all
quite weak but as teams we can be in
tribes you might say we can be strong or
even powerful right and so work on your
human network like for instance one uh
man and i use a veteran down in south
texas i met with him quite a bit he came
down to see me in mexico actually and we
talked about that
through he's like i'm gonna take care of
my community he's taking charge of this
little town in texas so he's like so
i've been taking inventory of who can do
what he's like there's this one old lady
she's really worried she's like
i don't have any money in all this he's
like well let's list down what are your
skills and she's like well
you know i can do this i know how to sew
and she knows how to canned food
there's one he's like canned food i need
that okay
you're going to be our official food
counter because that's going to be
really important and so you got a job
you know make yourself useful because
once you once you're like one of the
things i'm very useful for is accurate
information global recon and you know
giving you information that's actually
actionable right that makes me quite
useful and so i'll be welcoming any
tribe because i i can be eyes and ears
right uh that lady she can can food i
need to eat you know and so uh so we
have to work as a team
and right we have to work um the doctor
can do doctor stuff you know
you know
that's how you have to everybody has
more skills than they even imagined
right you like there's more skills in
your head than you can even think about
right now you know what i mean because
you you're probably not normally
thinking about them because you're
normally focused on uh doing other
things like doing
your very important podcast and these
sorts of things but let's say you know
our communications do go down and you
can't do podcasts anymore for some
period of time but you need to focus on
other stuff and so you'll have to you
know dig into your repertoire and
like make yourself useful and one of
those things that you're obviously good
at is talking with people and uh because
i've watched quite a few of your
podcasts you you know i've talked with
people you're a good listener i can tell
you let me ramble on and you know and
then and that's like and uh and uh and
um
and organize
organize
you know organizers are incredibly
important you know like that man in
south texas he's like
taking an inventory of his old town he
started with his church what are their
skills he's like i'm making a
spreadsheet who do i
he's getting people with radios so
because he you know assuming phones may
not work or power goes down radio up
right and uh you know getting all them
and you know we'll get through this it's
not like the end of the world our
everybody listening to this has
our family have been through all sorts
of hell our generations have been
through so many things
and uh
and we're here right so we're we're
natural survivors especially people that
are thinking ahead
not being afraid i'm a war court some
people say you know
since
january uh 2020 when i started warning
about famine uh people some people said
wow you've done so much war but you're
afraid now i'm like i'm not afraid i'm
just warning you uh i'm a workhorse fund
i've been in more fire fights than
you've seen in most movies right it's
like i i don't like them and they're not
fun but at the same time i continue to
go back to them right so i mean i'm
going to be fine i know i'm going to be
fine and you're going to be fine if you
think ahead and you work on your
networks and you think about your
resilience make sure you stockpile the
things that you need now that you won't
be able to get later
like
canning supplies you know the types of
salts that you need the types of vinegar
you know jars and a lot of stuff you
know what i mean and uh and then we'll
get through it and then when it's over
we'll be telling uh children our
children someday like how bad it was and
they'll think you're exaggerating and
you know
and uh yeah it'll be like it couldn't
have been that bad you'll be like yeah
well i was eating the horse's saddle i
had to boil it
oh my goodness